[Musique]
mélanie a reçu son compte de carte de
crédit
les fêtes ont coûté cher son compte
s'élève à 2500 $ en payant elle se
trompe et paye 2400 $ le mois suivant
une surprise l'attend à cause de ces 100
dollars qui n'ont pas été payés
on lui réclame 33 dollars en frais
d'intérêts bien élevés pour seulement
100 dollars pense-t-elle mais mélanie se
trompent
les intérêts sont calculés sur la
totalité des deux mille cinq cents
dollars
ce mode de calcul est conforme à la loi
d'abord mélanie a eu droit à un délai de
grâce entres ses achats et la date
d'échéance du paiement mais puisqu'elle
n'a pas payé la totalité du montant les
intérêts ont été calculés à partir des
dates d'achat et sur la totalité de la
somme le fin mot de l'histoire
les émetteurs jouent bien leurs cartes
soyez aussi rusé que comprenait les
règles du jeu